what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome back to top five Tuesday a
weekly series where we count down the
top 5 characters teams and concepts from
across geek culture and this week we're
counting down the top 5 worst comic-book
movies in the history of Hollywood and
for obvious reasons we're going to be
leaving off the Fantastic Four reboot
because it sucks really bad like we're
number 5 Judge Dredd when this film was
released in 1995 I didn't know who judge
shredd was or why he got a movie and to
be honest I still don't while Kyle
Urban's reboot was absolutely amazing
Sylvester Stallone's version leaves a
lot to be desired and by a lot I mean
almost everything taking place in a
dystopian future around the year 2080
the world has become virtually
uninhabitable with most people living in
giant cities that are overcrowded much
like today what used to be the criminal
justice system of course has been
replaced with cops that act as judges
immediately determining guilt and
carrying out executions on the spot the
story follows a pretty formulaic status
and that Judge Dredd is a good guy he's
framed for crimes sent to prison and
then breaks out for me there were only
three redeeming features to this film
Sylvester Stallone's lip Crowell Rob
Schneider and Diane Lane mm-hmm
Diane Lane well I was a little
disappointed that the film didn't have
lope and I will say that with Rob
Schneider playing the comedic relief in
the form of Herman Ferguson a movie that
would have otherwise been incredibly
boring saw a pretty good bit of fresh
air with Armando Santi playing the
villain rico and the brother of
sylvester stallone the movie essentially
comes down to mom's kids tearing up the
furniture while not the greatest of
endings seeing a robot Ripper man's
limbs off is pretty cool except they
didn't show the arms and legs being
ripped off and instead Bitto showed
blood I always wish they would have
showed the arms and legs being ripped
off number four the Green Lantern and so
this movie was like 90% CGI and if you
take Ryan Reynolds six back into account
it was 100% CGI even the face mask was
CGI and they could have bought one of
those for a dollar I know because I've
seen them online for a dollar the movie
would have been better if it had
featured Lohan but because it didn't
we'll work with what we got as one of
DC's most popular characters Green
Lantern fans were pissed when this movie
came out and that'll mean pissed as in
Warner Brothers why did you make this
film
I mean pissed as in this kid
[Applause]
in truth how Jordan was and still is a
mainstay for coming book fans and has a
back story that many people absolutely
adore as an example during the 1993 ml
Twilight story Hal Jordan went insane
after cyborg superman blew up his
hometown of coast city in turn he
recreated it with his ring started
talking to the ghostly apparitions he
made with his ring was kicked out of the
Green Lantern Corps for abusing his ring
killed everyone in the Green Lantern
Corps the guardians of the universe died
I mean the entire Green Lantern mythos
came crashing down over the course of a
three issues story so yeah Green Lantern
fans were pissed when they saw this
movie and understandably so I mean I get
that this movie was based off Geoff
Johns run from 2006 with Green Lantern
rebirth but come on Warner Brothers at
least act like you care about the
character all of the other characters
like Harold Ferris are boring which
sucks because she eventually becomes
Star Sapphire parallax the living
embodiment of fear looks like a
character from the Ghostbusters Hector
Hammond looks like one of others failed
attempt to continue the story of the
leader from the Incredible Hulk and
Sinestro doesn't do anything the entire
film and a half cocked attempt is made
to establish the yellow Lantern Corps at
the end of the movie number three x-men
Last Stand my god where to start first
things first this movie gets a strike
because it didn't have low pan having
said that if the guy who made x-men 1 &
2 comes back just to wreak on your film
then your movie probably sucks and not
only does it suck the film studio that
released it figured the world to be
better off pretending it didn't exist so
the movies based off two stories Chris
Claremont stark Phoenix saga and Joss
Whedon's the gifted The Dark Phoenix
saga was about the Phoenix force going
crazy after experiencing human emotions
and the gifted was about a cure
for mutants now I get the cure part and
I can see how mutants would disagree
over it but in an interesting turn of
events magneto goes from saying I think
mutants should be free of human control
and lead their own lives to saying no
mutants should have the Cure because the
government would use it against us so he
waits as the war in order to save
mutants from themselves I guess I don't
know either way the biggest problem with
this movie is Jean Grey I consider
myself well versed in her character and
have been reading her story since as far
back as I can remember so when I say
that Jean Grey in this film was
ridiculous
I'd like to think I know what I'm
talking about the problem with
emotionally insane Jean Grey in this
movie is that if brett ratner intended
to demonstrate her craziness by having
her stand around then i guess he hit the
nail on the head and the comics the Dark
Phoenix saga deals with the Phoenix
force replacing Jean Grey while the
wheel Jean heals from injuries in space
the Phoenix experiences human emotions
something that's never felt before
it's manipulated by a crazy guy named
jason wyngarde from the Hellfire Club
that breaks free of his control travels
throughout the universe destroys a world
and because she's basically insane the
most prominent races and the universe
decide she needs to die the Dark Phoenix
saga is amazing and continues to stand
the test of time as one of the greatest
Jean Grey stories ever told whatever it
was a Brett Ratner and his team were
thinking clearly had nothing to do with
the Dark Phoenix saga and if it did I
highly doubt they read the source
material I'd wager they read a Wikipedia
article and base the movie off of that
number two Howard the Duck so what I
want to know is this who thought it
would be a good idea to make this movie
the reason why is because that person
needs to be tied up and dropped off on
an island to spend the rest of their
days isolated from society I imagine
that if I saw the world through the eyes
of the Joker in the myths of a really
bad acid trip this is what the world
would look like but so the film centers
on Howard the Duck a creature that
hailed from an alternate dimension
composed of ducks instead of people
who's yanked into our dimension due to
an experimental device allowing
individuals to jump through alternate
realities while starts out crazy from
here the movie descends into complete
madness apparently there's some being
floating around called the dark overlord
or something like that that wants to
bring his own people into this dimension
Howard the Duck tries to bump uglies
with Lea Thompson butts blocked by Tim
Robbins the darker one word gets
destroyed but Lohan never shows up this
movie is the very definition of what it
means to be clinically insane and I
think that whoever made it
directly into that category number one
you know it was actually really
difficult picking the worst comic-book
movie of all time
assure those films like Batman and Robin
the spirit Jonah Hex Superman 3 any of
the fantastic four movies Ninja Turtles
three Spider Man 3 Ghost Rider Ghost
Rider 2 Elektra daredevil steel x-men
origins will reign just to name a few in
the end though I got to give the award
for the worst comic book movie of all
time to Catwoman
honestly and not even Lohan could have
saved this movie you know how they
always have a scene in a scary film
where the main stars fumbling around in
the dark looking for a light switch or
something well that was this movie what
made this film suck is that there were
small changes that weren't even
necessary I understand that sometimes
plots have to be adjusted or modified to
fit the silver screen but in this movie
cat woman's name is patience Phillips
and the comics cat woman's name is
Selina Kyle and I have a difficult time
understanding why the name change was
even made if it was because of some
convoluted backstory or something like
that it would have made sense to me
but nope it was changed because reasons
apparently patience works for a cosmetic
company which is owned by Sharon Stone
who hasn't been hot since Basic Instinct
in 1992 the product in question is a
beauty cream which advertises to reverse
the effects of aging
however it's revealed that if the cream
is taken for too long the users skin
becomes marbled and if it's not taken
long enough their skin disintegrates
Halle Berry overhears this tries to
escape and gets drowned by Sharon
Stone's goons and is brought back to
life by an Egyptian cat that apparently
operates as The Herald of bast the
Egyptian goddess of warfare Halle Berry
puts on a disguise fumbles through the
rest of the film Sharon Stone falls from
a building while her skin disintegrates
and thank God the credits roll my fellow
members of the robbed core I'm not a
Hollywood actor but I gotta ask did
Halle Berry even read the script for
this movie and if she did what in God's
name would lead her to join on unless
she was suffering from Nicolas Cage
level financial problems I have a hard
time understanding why she would make a
film that was destined to earn a rating
a Fantastic Four reboot with that being
said we're gonna bring this video to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed it and let
me know what your top 5 choices are for
the worst comic book movies of all time
and I will catch you guys on him peace
you